my entrepreneur friend Kevin David went
from working an accounting job that he
hated to in less than 18 months becoming
a millionaire using Facebook Ads Shopify
and Amazon FBA he now teaches people how
they can do the same in this video
Kevin's gonna teach us how to become a
millionaire the truth no one tells you I
hope you enjoy and there's a special
link below to get more free training
from Kevin all right thanks so much for
the interview and we're gonna be talking
about the world's most profitable
business model that I've ever found and
that we've used to create over 10
million dollars in revenue and help
10,000 students from around the world in
the last 18 months which is creating a
digital course and I want to prove to
you that you don't have to be a
world-class a leading expert to actually
get started so we're gonna talk about
how to choose your digital course topic
and how to get started creating your
digital course movement as soon as today
let's go alright so welcome into my
computer so what we're gonna talk about
right now is kind of a problem that a
lot of entrepreneurs have where they get
kind of caught up in what I like to call
toxic shiny object syndrome right so
shiny object syndrome basically means
jumping from one thing to the next to
the next never actually committing to
one thing long enough to really have
success with it and so what I want to
kind of get the point across in this
particular video is not necessarily
listening to what entrepreneurs are
saying or what people are saying but
instead of looking at what people do
right this is kind of one of the ways
that I was able to go you know from zero
to over ten million dollars in digital
course sales in 18 months because
instead of listening to necessarily what
people said I tried to instead look at
what they're actually doing right
because like these huge entrepreneurs
like Tony Robbins Dean grass COC you
know Brandon Rashard Grant Cardone right
these types of people are talking about
a lot of different things they're
talking about personal development real
estate courses right they're talking
about you know Cardone university
brandon brush arts courses they're
talking about a lot of different
opportunities right so at the end of the
day they're really good salesmen and
they're really good entrepreneurs and i
have a huge amount of respect for them
and you know I do I have a similar
business model but
the end of the day right tony robbins is
talking to you about personal
development dean grass COC is talking to
you about real estate right he's trying
to get you to buy a real estate course
as he should write a completely 100%
respected but at the end of the day
right what is he actually doing when
he's trying to sell you a real estate
course right he's spending his time
building and selling a digital course
right because building and selling a
digital course about investing in real
estate or going out and investing in
real estate yourself are two wildly
different business models right and it's
not just dean it's everyone right we do
the same thing brandon bashar does the
same thing grant cardone does the same
thing why are they actually spending
their time selling digital courses right
more so than actually doing the thing
the course teaches right because of one
very important principle selling a
course on investing in cryptocurrency or
real estate or whatever the case may be
right if you're selling a course on
investing in cryptocurrency versus
investing in cryptocurrency let's
actually it kind of evaluate the
differences right investing in
cryptocurrency itself takes money to get
started you actually have to go buy the
crypto there's a ton of inherent risk
right
Bitcoin crashed right all the other you
know smaller altcoins go up and down
wildly they're extremely volatile right
so there's a ton of inherent risk you
really have to know what you're doing
right it takes money to get started
versus selling a course on investing in
cryptocurrency think about the
difference right investing as selling of
course I'm investing in cryptocurrency
is zero money to get started right it
doesn't take anything to get started you
can literally sit in front of your
computer and record a video on your
screen right you could do it on your
phone even so it takes nothing to get
started there's no risk whatsoever and
it's an infinitely scalable product
meaning you can sell a course a billion
times and you never run out of stock
right there's no inventory cost there's
no traditional overhead there's none of
that which is why so many of the you
know quote unquote famous entrepreneurs
the household names the people you've
heard about the one of you know one of
if not their main source of income and
revenue comes from selling digital
courses because it's an incredibly
unique business model right and the
knowledge economy is a multiple hundred
billion dollar
a year actual industry and so you know
people that actually sell digital
courses are making an absolute fortune
doing so and you know so there's kind of
two mentalities about this you know
person a can be bitter about it saying
oh you know they're they're making more
money selling a course on real estate
than they are from actually investing in
real estate right that's person a you
don't want to be person a you don't want
to be bitter about it right you can you
can choose that but you could also be
person B who says well you know I made
some money investing in real estate now
I'm gonna teach other people how to do
it as well right and so those are the
people who are making seriously
significant money with a lot less work a
lot less employees a lot less risk and a
lot more scale right with less actual
capital and human human capital and
capital outlay right so digital courses
are the future and you can you know
either choose to accept it and create a
you know a real insignificant impactful
digital course Empire yourself and a
movement and help other people by
teaching them things that you're already
an expert in you know things that you
are a coach in and you know expert is
such a it's such a difficult word
because no one's born an expert Tony
Robbins doesn't have any you know
degrees in or psychiatry or anything
like that
but he's still one of the foremost
experts in personal development and and
psychology and things like that he
doesn't have any traditional credentials
so you know some people might not say
that he's actually a traditional expert
but you know Tony Robbins is worldwide
famous and known for being an expert in
the things he teaches being an expert
all that means is caring more about your
subject matter than other people right
being an expert basically means you know
having a moral commitment to research
and you know learn and use all the
different available resources about your
particular subject matter and committing
to becoming an expert all you have to do
to be able to help people is be enough
ahead of them at what they're trying to
learn to be able to provide value right
you should always be focusing on
providing value and that's what these
entrepreneurs do until they become the
best right they had a moral obligation
to research and understand these things
the deepest and then they became that
right and that's not to say you should
go out and like fake it and just like
build a course on whatever obvious
you have to have experience you have to
have you know some success yourself but
there's so many people out there like
you who are coaches or who have
service-oriented businesses who are just
working 80-hour weeks killing themselves
working with clients when instead they
can kind of take that same focus and
turn it into something like a digital
product right where you can sell a
thousand copies and it requires no
additional work because people can watch
your videos over and over and over again
and you can help you know hundreds if
not thousands of more people with no
additional manual effort yourself right
so that's the beauty of a digital course
so let's talk about how do you actually
choose your digital course subject so
there's three kind of evergreen silos
and what I mean by that is there's three
overarching categories for digital
courses they kind of never go out of
style health wealth and relationships
and what those three course topics
actually represent are kind of the three
pillars that I've built you know my
digital course secrets program on and
that I teach you know all of my students
actually kind of based their own course
topics on and then within these three
overarching categories you know there's
kind of subcategories like for example
wealth I've built you know for courses
now myself all of which all of which
have gone on to become multi-million
dollar courses when I started with
Amazon and then I created a Shopify
course and then I created a Facebook Ads
course and now I've created a course
helping coaches and service businesses
and people who want to kind of help
people and teach and get their message
out there to build their own digital
products to really create the best type
of business model when it comes to
creating a massive passive income stream
right and so health wealth and
relationships are the three things that
all people will always be interested in
everybody wants to get healthier get in
better shape everybody needs some level
of financial security and building and
wealth accumulation and everyone you
know people are here are social
creatures everybody needs help with
relationships how to you know talk to
women how to you know improve your
marriage there's there's billions and
billions and billions of dollars when it
comes to actually creating these types
of products and there's a lot of
different ways to see what types of
courses have already worked because of a
massive mistake that beginners make is
they think they want to go out and make
the first course of its kind right you
want to go out and make a course on
something you're passionate about
like Under
basket weaving right or something that
nobody in a million years would actually
buy a course about but this is a huge
mistake right competition in courses is
a good thing
competition means that people are buying
these types of products and competition
is kind of what tells you that this that
this particular course is selling and
it's going to be a good use of your time
and then you know instead of thinking
that you don't want competition just go
out and get your message out there in a
more effective way
right there's very very effective ways
to communicate and then there's much
less effective ways to communicate and a
lot of the course creators nowadays are
focusing on the wrong things so if we
look right here what we can see is you
know there's a lot of different proven
course topics out there there's so many
different resources there's literally a
website where you can go out and see
what different types of business owners
have made at least a million dollars
with their particular course idea or
funnel or business right there's there's
Clickbank there's all these different
there's udemy there's all these
different types of websites that show
you literally with social proof the most
popular course topics right so there's a
lot of different resources out there
that we've kind of put together where
you can see literally what successful
courses have been in the past and then
kind of use that to help you craft your
particular offer but let's look at some
of these right How to Lose
post-pregnancy Baby Phat we can see jump
rope how to paint' chiropractic
marketing dental marketing biohacking
vertical jump how to run Airbnb expert
at waking men up right and I don't I
don't think they literally mean waking
them up like from sleep I mean waking a
man up right dating how to be a landlord
how to fly a drone water watercolor
painting spiritual life coaching
hairstylist network marketing dyslexia
speed reading right all of these types
of things that you might not think are
possible to create a course they are
possible and I can promise you some of
these like how to jump higher right
Jacob Hiller he made over a million
dollars with his how to jump higher
course I've seen people make hundreds of
thousands of dollars with how to play
piano how to you know digital paint so
if you're thinking to yourself well I'm
not an expert of anything trust me when
I tell you that you are right you just
need to figure out how to actually
choose the right thing and then market
that right so there's courses on all
different types of things you know
what I would what I would leave you with
is look at what successful entrepreneurs
are actually doing and I promise you
that most of the people that you follow
and listen to most of them are selling
some type of digital course or digital
product of some kind because it's the
best business model on earth right
there's no other business model that
I've ever found and I've looked harder
than most people where you can go from
nothing right two years ago I had zero
followers I had zero anything and you
know in a little over 1.5 years I went
from zero right being an accountant
trapped in my cubicle to creating a 10
million dollar plus business all because
of digital courses and focusing on the
right that all right guys I hope you
enjoyed that quick look into the world's
most profitable business model how to
create a digital course movement you
know what we've been able to do in the
past 18 months creating over 10 million
dollars in revenue and helping 10,000
students from around the world and Evan
does have one more quick thing a
surprise for you guys so make sure you
check it out again thanks for having me
and I can't wait to hear from you guys
soon
kevin is having a free webinar training
to take you deeper and show you
step-by-step how you can make more money
if you're interested in checking it out
the link is in the description below if
you want Kevin's advice on how to start
social media marketing check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there I'm going to show you how
you can create an SM MA business and
start earning thousands and thousands of
dollars per month
setting up very simple Facebook Ads